il a d'abord à balancer cette brosse à
dents à castaldi cardon alors qu'il
roulait à contresens en moto en plein
paris benjamin castaldi s'est fait
arrêter il a proposé un sel fille en
échange pour sauver les trois heures qui
lui restait
et wes post une source daniel moreau
hélas c'est vrai que le bien public et
alors ils vous ont mis les trois points
mais on ne verra le fou du cmfi comment
gérer les 3 points non et non ils ont
été très gentils ah oui ouai ouai c'est
trop bien je remercie la police mais on
s'est vraiment je suis pas le faire ont
tous
été sympa oui mais la vraie question
c'est pourquoi tu l'as pris en contre ça
ouais c'est vrai en moto en plus pour
nous et je sais pas je devais le pressé
je pense pas
mais qu installer vous prenez pour qui
vous avez ya 20 ans allumé une émission
qui a marché 300
[Applaudissements]
posséder une fois une fois je m'étais
fait arrêter par la police et j'allais
un peu trop vite et je fais des photos
et tout le monde sur le débat ça va ça
va ça passait comme ça où j'étais des
photos et toute la police et après il
est bon maintenant la
voilà temps en temps voilà dix ans bravo
comment vous savez ça vous étiez
derrière dans la boîte
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa vie
[Rires]
tu gâches
avec beaucoup d'eux
quand elle vous attrape nigaud
des mots-clés plus que les bombes sont à
côté
une série
l'équipe mp il faut qu'il montre moi tes
de leurs maux cyril a poussé un coup de
gueule en demandant à tous les chronos
tous les chroniqueurs d'être présent à
18h pile tous les soirs tout le monde
est désormais à l'heure mais sauf
mathieu delormeau qui se pointe à 18h15
en se moquant de ses petits camarades
faux car je cite j'avais beau bas
n'osera s'élever face à moi ouais
c'est vrai
j'en appelle à notre ami tu si j'en
appelle à
tous à la chaîne a jamais vous c'est
pour en faire un peu plus tard tandis
que je travaille en amont ensuite parce
qu'il se trouve que niveau maquillage
j'ai un petit peu moins besoin de temps
que mes petits camarades non c'est la
seule raison il y aura un écriteau à
partir de nyala
les gens mettent un deuxième carton
jaune il en a rien à faire alors il en a
tout plein de dents hier mais dites moi
votre rêve je serai là
14h10 16 heures c'est fait
le défendez tout le temps c'est vrai
alors à
source kelly vais devenir voilà là bon
c'est vrai ça c'est guillaume arrive
toujours un peu plus tôt studio non pas
pour bosser l'émission mais pour pourrir
les toilettes des loges ça devient
invivable
[Rires]
pour le reste de l'équipe
c'est vrai pourtant vous avez l'air tout
propre vous avez un ballon ou chier du
gala
[Rires]
double dauphin qui sont là
[Applaudissements]
mon galaxy blanc ou si non c'est vrai
c'est arrivé une fois la semaine
dernière et c'est la faute de valérie
benaïm
en fait voilà le nom m'échappe et
plusieurs semaines qu'elle me tanne pour
goûter des gâteaux qu'elle a préparée
chez elle je voulais donc je refuse
poliment les jours elle insisté la femme
devenue menaçante
j'en ai mangé deux voulaient que les
finissent devant elle et ça n'a pas
loupé quinze minutes plus tard j'étais
en train de faire des choses qui a subi
un effet de levier aux gens puisque je
peux maintenant dire la vérité parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut arrêter de
mentir guillaume tous les jours tu
arrives ici à la factory sa belle ça me
dégoûte tu va directement dans les
toilettes moselotte arrivent en course
qui se maintient c'est la vérité même si
les témoins sur léman site enfermé dans
les toilettes l'a fait là et on s'est
toujours dit mais qu'est ce qui fait
qu'en fait on croise qui fait dans ce
marathon à l'odeur on sait ce qu'ils
ont si tu fais pas beaucoup qu'on a mené
l enquête
pendant une semaine on s'est faufilé
derrière toi et bien rendu compte que tu
exterminer les toilettes
qui seraient stressés paris c'est le
trac c'est que c'est diffuser la
gelée je vous ai vu science
perez et leurs artères tout à l'heure
tellement été prêtés devenant alors sa
douzième anniversaire pour éviter les
bruits
c'est le train comme ça que jacques brel
vomissait avant chaque concert bon ben
ali fille
[Rires]
ça merci donc fait encore rêver ni
benjamin pour castanet a profité de la
notoriété de cyril pour se faire offrir
une trottinette en disant promis je fais
des photos à côté de baba girondine
remanié à l'intersaion de urban libre
c'est vrai il est très très déçu si ça
permet d'avoir une photo de vous avec la
trottinette et avec benjamin et qu'il a
juste profité la trottinette sans vous
la monty en fait j'utilise il utilise la
freinant tout ce qui te ferai moi alors
non j'ai grâce à kelly grâce à qui j'ai
obtenu copie dette en échange de postes
que j'ai fait voilà
sans cyril j'aimais pas réussi à le
trouver et est pas la nôtre
voilà ma bonne on veut ça me dérange pas
à
baa1 ok c'est ça ce voit la scierie de
parent et réclamant de l'argent avec ses
chroniqueurs à problèmes ce n'est jamais
le ciré puisqu'ils demandent aux
assistants de plaques toit n'était pas
des bénéfices a
fait tout le temps des paris avec
benjamin avec mathieu avec tous ceux qui
sont là et au moment de dire non a dit
balla les dix bals hockey benjamin sore
sans n'osait y vous faites comme si dieu
comme si vous les aviez sur vous on vous
les avez jamais vous vous retournez vers
les assistants amaury alex
[Applaudissements]
allez
l'attentât horrible si tu la mets au
tribunal elle dira la vérité risque
avant qu'alex ne prenne la parole il n'y
aura aucune sanction à son encontre quoi
ton cul et il le sait il me connaît on
travaille ensemble depuis des années
[Rires]
aujourd'hui je
fais justement est juste une chose la
vérité
ne prenne la parole je termine dans ma
cantine quand vous gagnez vous gardez
losail celui de celui qui vous après dix
ans
aucun jour je regarde d'abord allé voir
le vrai visage de ben ali
la mythomane
valérie bénaïm j'avais menti et j'ai la
chance d'avoir ici un témoin oculaire et
sion sur le témoin il n'y a aucune
pression je lui demande juste la vérité
y'a pas tout blanc si je lui demande
juste le levé la main droite et dire je
le jure je le jure mais je dirai la
vérité la chine voilà s'il te plaît alex
dit la vérité parce que j'en ai marre
alors oui en effet pour les jeux cyril
[Rires]
et à la fin du jeu même à la fin
d'émission il nous redonne toujours
l'argent et même des fois un peu plus le
des pourboires
m
bien entendu je me relis
sévérité des terrains plus mon agent
j'ai fait à paris contre vous vous
n'avez pas les d euros vous m'avez donné
à lagos qui était adorable
on va passer super pukki voilà
voilà
on veut tous qu'ils aient pas notre nom
à
tous qui est pas notre nom l'a
choisi
ajax n'est pas de hasard
[Musique]
oh la vache c'est mauro le pas qui nous
regardent et
[Musique]
là je ne savais pas je la découvre c'est
grave docteur cgil qui a pourtant malgré
ce qu'il affirme
un des trois bornes eater ici a bien eu
une relation buccale 1 avec un
journaliste
je vais donner les données et cela ne
s'est pas passé qu'une seule fois
regarde la barre
de regarder la regarde la ville sont
gilles verdez oui c'est vrai et quoi
c'est vrai tu aimais même s'est passé
pour parler de genton le pôle du calife
et kaka tout le temps c'est vrai qu'à
la fois puissant et c'est vrai que sur
notre plateau l'éminent journaliste
jordan de luxe a révélé qu'il avait
embrassé sur la bouche guillaume genton
avec jardin bien nous avons enquêté
c'est d'abord vrai et ensuite si
guillaume est honnête et il est il va
raconter la nuit torride qu'ils ont
passé ensemble
aubry jette pas la pierre vous avez tout
à fait normalement c'est très bien ça
sinon les peurs vous dire toute la
vérité en fait jour dance est un ami de
longue date et il ya quelques années il
traversait une période difficile et très
bon millésime a traversé une période
difficile donc il m'a demandé de venir
chez lui pour le réconforter en tant que
potes donc je suis allé chez lui
on s'est mis sur son canapé sous un
plaid devant la cheminée
un jour vraiment très triste et un fin
de vie
il y avait des gouttes qui ruisselait
sur les fenêtres j'étais sûr que c'était
dans la foulée sera un
jour très triste il était vraiment en
dépression mais à un moment il s'est mis
à trembler donc gilles a éclaté en
sanglots je lui ai pris la main et jeudi
mais jordan qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour que tout aille mieux il m'a regardé
dans les yeux et m'a dit bof molecule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Rires]
si vous êtes embrasser ce programme et
sa série n 1 vous avez dit de dire la
vérité il a dit vous le virer
[Musique]
des fonds tous les goûts
[Applaudissements]
gildas enquête mais j'ai fait un petit
bisou entre potes comme ça ce fait
l'accord sur la bouche avec leurs
singles aux cerises
ces dépressions
[Rires]
je crois que ball mais ça n'est pas de
battre associe nom alors je savais faire
des petites saynètes des gays
mérite et moi ça me fait plaisir il peut
en être un ami moi j'aurais été avec
daniel
derniers jours
les shérifs
matthieu delormeau
lors de la galette des rois avec toutes
ces équipes ce qu'on a fait une galette
des rois avec toutes les équipes de
besoin en est une une cinquantaine de
personnes ah bon et à l'instar de
vladimir poutine et kim jong-un
cyril hanouna mais la chance inespérée
d'obtenir la faire
je voulais que vous avez dû vous dans la
vérité bah je ne dis rien d'autre que la
vérité et la chambre il a travaillé
sans merci alors dit prêt à vous aider
comme témoin à bien des gens qui vous
appartiennent
sanna persson annonça perd cette merde
alors vous avez une série très gentiment
a fait une galette des rois en petit
comité h2aude
voilà tout à fait effectivement chacun
une part il y avait qu une faible sur
les 153 parce que avec une chance
incroyable et la chance sourit aux gens
qui ont du talent c'est cyril hanouna
qu'a eu la fève amaury ouais mais cyril
a choisi sa part en dernier donc
malheureusement c'est les autres qui ont
choisi leur part et si en dernier donc
c'est lui qui a eu la fève par chance en
fait à l'étude en fait il a toujours dû
du cusems chance et en plus il a donné
sens voilà merci amaury parce que je
commence à en avoir assez bien plus apte
à donner ton cadeau il ya donné santé
des salariés exactement c'était quoi le
cadeau une box un an partir en voyage
aux jambes lourdes
les irlandais yeux oui je n'ai jamais
triché à je vous le jure que c'est vrai
et il était là quand j'ai eu la fève je
vous jure voilà donc c'est vrai c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas triché mais elle voulait pas
mais je voulais pas garder les cadeaux
et voilà souvenez-vous l'année la bravo
voilà non mais là aujourd'hui je remets
les
venir la garden party
pour qui la cites
[Rires]
est longue envolée en venaient d'eux
maintenant
contrairement à ce qu'elle dit
géraldine maillet se rendre et en toute
discrétion manif anti vax
doré moustache pour une fois que ça
c'était à refaire on a des photos en
exclusivité
mais dans les crèmes ou non
j'ai une vraie
on a entendu dans les loges daniel parlé
à sa mère souffre benjamin castaldi
aulas en dix ans elle est résistante la
vieille mais je l'aurais une manière ou
d'une autre
elle parle et d'isabelle et vous savez
que j'aime beaucoup et isabelle à ce qui
s'est passé c'est vrai si c'est vrai
pari c'était en sortie d'une émission
elle est remonté comme un coucou et à la
paix sa mère y aller ça y est je pense
que je vais l'avoir même bien résisté la
vieille je l'aurais je m'inscris en faux
je peux même vous amener ma mère qui
s'en souvient
avait dit qu'on serait d'ailleurs
j'avais un autre témoin qui étaient
cachées comme d'habitude et se planquer
c'est le corbeau gide
et la situation s'envenime entre les
deux qui vous voit des sms
alors on essaiera de vous réconcilier
c'est ce sera très difficile seul vous
pouvez le faire mais je vais essayer
puis c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens
qui nous dit li vend pas de son bar
enfants mais c'est vrai que c'est pareil
c'est vrai on va vous répondre à la
semaine prochaine je ferai peut-être
même une émission donc peut-être même
demain des émissions avec daniel et
isabelle
vraiment pour décompresser les missions
du chabab viser la cible jeune
il ya plein de gens qui commençaient à
fantasmer sur daniel way tueur c'est
vrai mais là j'ai découvert les dm là et
j'ai plein moment là c'est trop et on a
regardé crémont parce que j'avais 99
demande non
mais qu'il est mort
enfin avoir du passage
allez juste envoyer quelques
tractions
et
rattrape